good afternoon everybody welcome to the
Academy's Linwood done theater here in
Hollywood my name is Ellen Harrington I
am the co curator with Lourdes Portillo
of the Academy's Pacific Standard Time
los angeles latin america project that
has been going on now since
mid-september it was funded by the Getty
so we want to thank the Getty very much
for putting together the opportunity for
the Academy to do an in-depth project on
the intersection between Latin America
and Los Angeles specifically around
cinema we also want to acknowledge Bank
of America for the funding involved and
we started a screening program in
mid-september as well as launching a
website a publication a number of other
resources showing our oral history is
online all index so that people can
really have an in-depth experience of
understanding all of these cross
influences between Latino Chicano and
Latin American filmmakers and we did a
lot of oral histories throughout Latin
America including many in Mexico that
can all be seen online and we have our
screening program as three months long
today is a full day
we've got los pequeños Jigen days now
which thank you very much for joining us
later this evening we have Stand and
Deliver and in between there's a
workshop that if you haven't already
signed up especially if there's children
here
it's a storyboard workshop with Mike
Backus and it's going to be wonderful
it'll happen immediately outside right
after and I think we still have all the
snacks all the baseball snacks are
available and then there's a few more
screenings I just want to alert you to
on Monday evening we're screening
Amore's perros and we have the film's
composer Gustavo Santo hiya Alya who's
coming to do some acoustic performance
of the music in the film the following
Monday night we have Maria Navarro
coming from Mexico to present her film
done stone the week after that December
4th we have deep crimson with Arturo
Ripstein and Paz Garcia Diego also
coming from Mexico City and will end on
December 11th with El Norte with Gregory
Nava who's actually now a govern
for the Academy and that film has been
restored by the Academy Film Archive
also the film you'll see today los
pequeños Gigantes has been restored by
the Academy Film Archive so thanks to
the team there for making such a
commitment to having these films in
excellent condition and viewable for the
public in our archive after the film
we're going to have a discussion and we
are so lucky we have two of the original
little league baseball players from
Mexico who are in the film I'm Hannah
Macias and pit bay mice they will join
us afterwards also Margo pepper who as
you might have seen in the slideshow
thought her father is a very important
player in this scenario and she'll tell
us more about his role in the story
we'll also have one of the former Dodger
players Denis Powell joining us at the
end of the film so he'll talk about the
contemporary Dodgers which came really
close this year they didn't quite make
it but they it was a very exciting
series and also Claudia fuss the
daughter of say some fuzz the legendary
coach and hero of the little giants is
here with some of the members of the
family so we're thrilled to have so much
in person representation for this
important film all the way back from
1957 when these guys were just kids and
to welcome you also and to tell you a
little bit more about the film we have
somebody who is deeply connected also
with the Los Angeles Dodgers who is the
broadcaster for the spanish-language
broadcast of the Dodger games please
join me in welcoming Pepe India's
and actually now Pepe I'm gonna welcome
you up here and it's your turn to talk
to the audience so Pepe you [ __ ] thank
you thank you thank you very much good
afternoon everybody
it's a pleasure being here I think it is
likely like uhit's unbelievable
experience to look at the classic movies
for 1957 for this these guys like they
made amazing history in baseball not
just from mexico para for the whole
baseball and I was talking about for
what Alejandra one of the people's
involved in this event when I made uncle
Macias and pepper mais in Mexico
of course I watched the movie I saw the
movie already a long time ago and I saw
that perfect game that latest but UH one
of my experience and I think that I
wanna I wanna share with you is probably
mid 70s so close to 7:00 mid 70s when I
saw I held my SIA same pepper my cinema
seus I remember he played for los
monado's they must land in a winter ball
and he was I remember exactly the three
outfielders gray outfielders was odious
Macias in Osuna LPD Osuna in I made
uncle Macias when I was probably seven
eight years old at the time and he was
younger that time also he was probably
and early 20s or 20 21 22 years old but
it was all salary as a professional
player so when I met him I never
realized like that when the movie was I
mean the wall series was fifty years
after the IRA seen by him and by pepper
mice also to Dodger Stadium to celebrate
50 years
Cinda the grave
wall shears happen and then we in sports
in Pennsylvania so in now is 60 years
seen that time and now we are lucky to
have these two gray heroes in right here
and this and this theater in take a
picture with them get a autograph and I
think it is unbelievable unbelievable
memories for everybody here I hope
everybody enjoy enjoy a there because we
don't want to see them every every
single day because you know Macias live
in Mexico pepper mice is another Delta
the other former player playing 57 and I
think pepper my sis most most us our
investment in like like like a person
like Iran the team in a Mexico like
Monterrey
so he's the order of the team so that is
a very very traditional team in Mexico
like Dodgers and maoli baseball so I
think we're very proud about them we are
very happy for these two peoples in a
very happy for having you here to watch
this great great movie so ready for the
movie okay let's let's see the movie
let's watch the movie enjoy the movie
los pequeños again to the Ventura
you
movie and then have the two stars in
person so please welcome hyung head
Macias is here ahead and Jose Pepe mice
please have a seat
and Dennis Powell from the Dodgers and
Margo pepper please come and join us the
daughter of George pepper the producer
so please sit right here thank you
so I want to ask both of the players
here how when is the last time you saw
the movie is it a movie you see often
and we have Alejandro to translate for
us if you need do you understand English
oh yes well the last time I was out two
years ago and also the movie that came
after the perfect game that was 2010 and
for this I love this we lot better
because first because he's more true
like a documentos and also because we
were reactors excellent acting that's
that's why como se sienta stead Debbie
to topple Akula when obseunikka sumeul
it appearance otra sister disability
amend the Sunna película que nunca nunca
la posada de tiempo por que tiene muchas
cosas bonitas in total triactol película
entonces creo que tiene muchas cosas muy
bonitas que podemos approve HR mañana
pasado cualquier dia Eclat n Gamow speci
present a las Casas
he feels he feels the movie is full of
beautiful messages that apply to today
and to the future and he feels very
happy about watching the movie so how
close was this movie to your real
experience because there's some footage
some historical documentary footage and
then you have all of the team is played
by the real players and yet you had to
learn how to act and remember your lines
so what was the transition like from
being the players to being to being
actors in a real movie well we didn't
have any any activation or before but
they were working with us and every week
we had to go in the morning or in the
afternoon to film this sense and most of
the time daily midian really had to work
too much with us because there were guys
that kind of ability to not like the
culture of the perfect game Norberto but
we are real Fidel Ruiz I think he made a
great paper over there and Angel well he
he did very good and also at the end of
the movie when you see all those all
that crowd trying to grow into the entry
field when Cesar comes and takes Angelo
up those are freely since of the movie
because at that time all the games were
only transmitted by radio not worth it
not by TV and those sins for I have told
is that some of the fans took it with a
own films and
I don't know how the producers did but
they call they got those those those
films to put it into the into the movie
at the end
those are real sense of the movie those
are completely true and I think that
most of the movie is real truth only I
want to say this at the end in the sixth
inning there were three strikeouts no no
no mori because he this is a perfect
game that he won't say it what I will
say it he was so perfect that no one
ball was hit to the outfield where 11
strikeouts and seven flies around us or
grounds into the infield I was suddenly
filled this airfield and the right-field
no one of us had nothing to do you had
an easy game very easy game a come off
way sir
either whoever the baseball accompanying
actor come off all experience a way back
to our memory Sala frases a la película
de Lobo Ueno Yoga is the Tulsa Cano look
at the enormous a mr. Puckett a is the
bush como la forma de como podemos
never film a co neat always Oh
siempre simple pensando en que podemos
hacer las cosas como debería pero de
repente AOC camos to Ihram mass nose
area Mo's Kelley keep off we're movin
exactly I meant the window Ramos a final
de Quinta's he's saying basically that
they had high standards of work that
they tried their best
sometimes he things didn't go the right
way went you know but they were very
high
no basically they D had to memorize all
of the dialogue which was a lot of work
but they had a good time they had a very
they were very very fun time it's so
natural it's hard to believe that you
weren't actually trained actors you know
I mean it's just remarkable as a movie
it works incredibly well so
congratulations you all deserve some
Oscars Margot I want to ask you about
your father's role in producing the film
and how what it means to you to have him
acknowledged in this in this way with
the credit on the film well this is the
first time that I see my father's name
recognized in the United States thanks
to the Academy of Motion Pictures and it
for me it felt like when it felt as
though someone had who has stolen
something really valuable like a title
to a home being restored again and it
felt also the way I feel when if someone
were to come up to me at my father's
memorial and or someone who I really
esteem and someone who I look up to
would say you know I really knew your
father and this is I'm gonna tell you
all about him
that's what it felt like to be
acknowledged
and his role in making the movie I guess
I should backtrack and say he was
blacklisted along with a lot of people
in Hollywood for wanting things that we
all want now like universal health care
college education and and for these
things he he was blacklisted along with
a lot of other people not just in
Hollywood and many filmmakers producers
and writers in Hollywood found refuge in
Mexico and found work in Mexico during
the 1950's
when there when my father's past where
it was seized in in I think it was
spring of 1951 after Edward Dmytryk
informed on him and named his name he he
had to his passport was seized and a lot
of people fled to Canada and Mexico
because you didn't need passports to go
there and his role in making the movie I
guess he met Luis buñuel in Mexico and
introduced Hugo Butler to the Hugo
moesel was his pseudonym and my dad's
name was George were caught they had to
take these names because they were put
on a list where they couldn't find work
unless they used pseudonyms and when he
met he introduced Hugo Butler to Luis
buñuel and when I knew Luis buñuel the
most I admired about him was his swing
set he gave me this little gold pestle I
was just a child but Luis then I guess
Hugo Butler which who wrote this
screenplay
they made he made four films with my
father and this was one of my favorites
well it's honor for the Academy Film
Archive to be able to restore the film
to restore the credit so thank you so
much for being here sometimes you can
fix his history or at least put things
right after a while so Dennis tell me as
a longtime player I bet you grew did you
grow up in Little League and did you
ever go to the Little League World
Series yourself no I didn't go to Little
League World Series but I did grow up in
Little League I've had a couple
opportunities recently to throw out the
first pitch in San Bernadino I did it
twice they're been with the Dodgers but
know it but I did come up around the
game Little League and I had the chance
though in 1996 to play on Pepe's team in
Monterrey the SU tannins and we actually
win the championship down there so I
haven't seen it in 21 years so this is
the first time in 21 years I mean this
is it's a small world and just like you
said I mean I watched the perfect game
and I watched this and I think the the
opposite field
yeah because you have the two players
here telling you certain things were
added and what the real parts were I
think this made it more real and but
there's so many so many headlines in
that movie just wall breakers because
I'm from a small town of 675 people and
I'm not having a glove my club had a big
hole in it and having mismatched socks
on and just seeing the journey that they
traveled I mean it just brought back so
many memories of my own story and just
it's just amazing it's amazing that
destiny is gonna always reach his goal
and you guys were there he was he was
hope closer he was all closer for we won
the championship in 1996 any spy will
[Applause]
so when you see this movie it's a very
emotional experience for you yes yeah
very much so emotional because like I
said knowing that the journey you take
and and you know coming up in 1968 down
in Georgia I was born and raised in
Georgia and there was racism still there
and and for me it was a Caucasian man
that gave me the opportunity to play
baseball and so I can just you know some
of the stuff that they went through in
Texas coming across the border and it
just kind of hit home you know knowing
that somebody crossed the border and
somebody crossed that racial barriers
and and and extended this game to me and
not knowing that it would one day lead
me to play in the major leagues and do
so many other things but yeah a lot of a
lot of serious moments in it for me that
I can really grab hold - yeah it's
really it's very emotional and it's
great to see the impact that it has on
people who love the sport yes and
obviously you both had a choice you
could go and be movie stars or you could
play baseball and both of you guys chose
careers in baseball so well he he was
signed by by the California Angels I was
going to be signed by the San Francisco
Giants what my fired en let me go he
want me to study because we were just 12
rolls and sisters I was the oldest of
the 12 he want me to be a civil engineer
I'm going he got the chance to buy the
team the Atilla team Monterrey Sultan's
he bought it and he told me I could not
I didn't let you go to play baseball but
you are here in the professionals
baseball and he gave me the Sultana
steam in 1986
ah hell a la pregunta es usted cuando
esta película de puesto adopts Ernest
sale jugando Oh sir dr. may many poor
who were just to play CS team attention
el baseball participate con una keepo
con equipos de lima he Cana inclues oh
no esto con la oportunidad de la primera
vez una serie de Caribe del Caribe in
this towel news in Puerto Rico
este es interesante que porra email Paso
por a circuit he chose to play and he
played the leagues in Mexico including
in the Caribbean League series he was
the first Mexican here in the Caribbean
sailors because he was the the lead of
here of the first Mexican team that
participated in the Korean series at
Puerto Rico he was the first Mexican
here
and say steadfast tell us a little bit
about him is he really as wonderful as
it seems in the movie was he like a
mentor and inspiration to both of you I
think he was for us a great great
instructor great money but the more the
best he had was a great psychological
guy because we came from four different
teams and he had to choose the best 14
guys of the four teams we can never play
together before until he Garros and put
us in giving us training every day for
about a month four hours daily at that
time you didn't drink get Gatorade or
something like that they gave us salt
pills in order to to practice and not
get internal get down so that's the way
we train it and because we trained it in
the fields that were not as good at the
American fields I think that gig
gave us a good chance when we came to
state because we're we were accustomed
to stones and glass and all that in the
in the field we didn't have fans in
Monterey in Montreuil the the was the
feel as you saw it in the seal in the
indie film and there they put chalk in
the in the well defenses should be and
then they put a little bit a little flux
and for any of you hear it over the flux
was a homerun if you hit it by the soil
it was a double so when you wake in to a
state for us it was easier to play in
these grass fields than to be playing
with the stones and glasses and
everything so I think that helped us did
you really roll on the grass oh yes
[Laughter]
uncle K significances are fast pero
State una persona que mucho siempre todo
y los ensign las who ghada's participa
back on Oso Tros siempre Indaba tres de
nosotros park a podium a hora que
podamos mejor are nosotros en cada una
de los vientos que su participa yo via
meant a few una persona que con nosotros
siempre se porto de lo mejor yo somebody
dad of course he was a coach he trained
him very well in every game he they
would review the games and find better
ways of doing things he was always
making sure they would do better each
time and he was very positive in their
lives so on his record I want to ask
each of the players to throw a perfect
game in the Little League World Series
only happened this one time this is the
gentleman who did it do you think
anybody will ever do it again I'll take
a alguien Bob eres el juego perfecto to
sterilise Oh megusta reah CC me gustaría
que alguien man y'know pasado Stengel
oportunidades
pero he would like indeed somebody
tomorrow soon to do so such a perfect
game but it's gonna be a uphill battle I
don't I don't think so because perfect
games are I mean they're hard I mean
even with the kind of pictures we have
now we do have kids that are very
talented with very strong arms and an
arsenal of pitches but it's just that
perfect game is just it's just so hard
to do without a base on balls or you
know it's you know it's just hard so I
don't think so you're going down in
history well they always you know we
talk about Don Drysdales
5050 seven innings been you know I'm
breakable and then Hershiser did it
but this one I think is this one that's
really even tougher than that you know
yeah really really amazing and
impressive
so I want to invite the whole audience
not just the children anyone who'd like
to stay and do the storyboard workshop
it's about to begin so unfortunately I
could stay here all day with these
gentlemen but we do have to wrap it up
thank you so much thank you all for
being here and for the wonderful month
of a shirts you guys I almost I have to
say I grew up in Boston I almost wore my
Red Sox shirt today but then I decided
not we just acknowledge Mon today and
Dodgers and great year Dodgers really
great year
[Applause]
and thank you all for coming on a
beautiful Saturday afternoon to watch
baseball the way it's meant to be played
rather thank you to the Academy for it -
here we are really happy and I just want
to ask you a question as you want to put
this movie again on the on the tears
because this is so nice now that you
clean everything and is so nice this yes
we should find out our archivist will
know who has the rights and maybe we can
figure out how to share it right and you
can find my website margo pepper calm
and please I want to make it publicly
accessible in any way that we can do
this I am if the Academy has a way to do
it
Olmec productions I'm the sole heir so
and I want to tell you one thing this
movie they allow people from Houston and
Chicago and Dallas they asked us for
copies and they use it in for motivation
movies in football and basketball um and
in many sports not only baseball so I
would like to see it got to see that
movie to be again in in the in the chops
off wherever they can buy it because
many people and they all write comments
to the audience thank you thank you for
the invitation and I hope to see you
soon here
all right thank you all so much good
afternoon
[Applause]
you